freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
heute ist alles anders denn ich stehe
bei dem einzig wahren sturm waffe denn
sturni kocht heute den gesamten tag für
mich ich hatte die idee ich habe sagte
sturm alle leute fans bestimmt niebels
cool wenn mal jemand für mich einen tag
kochen würde und was ich bereit erklärt
fast seine wertvollste zeit privat fit
und ich habe zum frühstück von ihr
shooter gewünscht jetzt wirst schon
eingekauft und über das einfach an dich
ich bin voll bereit und hallo war
hinterher leute jetzt natürlich die
besten produktionen noch mit drin ja wir
haben diverse sachen einkaufen erstmal
geht natürlich an schnippeln und im
prinzip ist ganz einfach nur wir machen
knoblauch zwiebel klein wir machen
unsere typische paprika losgeht sagt
penny gesagt zum beispiel wir schneiden
die die zwiebeln serien plan
wir schneiden sie zwiebeln sehr klar
okay
zwiebel wer zuerst geschnippelt und
luchs dieses wunderbare waffe brett
leider nicht mehr erhältlich aber fast
noch bis vor kurzem und wird wieder
kommt etwas wird wieder kommen ja
sozusagen eine waffel brett ist sehr
hart das wird einfach nur qvc weil ich
die bibel ist dankbar wären dazu den
ganzen tag über so viel zeit nimmt man
lernt stetig dazu deutlich dass ein
stück ist israelisches nationalgericht
wie es auch ziemlich nordafrika sehr
wenn die bauern in nordafrika sie lief
also ich hab das zum beispiel zum ersten
mal als nordafrikanischem orbán gegessen
frühstück heuer das unterscheidet sich
dadurch die gewürze die man rein knallt
in die wolga
aber ansonsten ist das gleiche bild ihr
werdet sehen ist supereinfach und hätten
eine sehr leichte alternative für leute
die in ihrem leben schon sehr viel gut
gefrühstückt knoblauch als nächstes die
beiden public keys werden jetzt
aufgeschlitzter ich mich auch letzten
jahrhundert bei normale fabrik habe ich
inzwischen passabel niemand wie man
schneidet und hier habe ich dann glaube
ich in der mitte die aufmacht dann habe
ich mir dann löffelchen genommen da
kannst du nämlich die ganzen general
hier und die ganzen kernchen einfach
raus schälen das jetzt fühlt sich das
wahrscheinlich für die zuschauer im
green day video wenn ich so nicht
der kamera immer kommentiere ich finde
es aber gut nur die frage ist halt jetzt
können wir uns mit dem stock hoch traden
zu einer rolex dass sich hier klar ich
habe mir die frage gestellt und jürgen
statement zu hohen öl sehr gut aber man
kann natürlich auch öl machen waren und
kalt war das fein gewürfelt war alles
was man sich vorstellen kann zwiebeln
und knoblauch brüssel schon immer so
genug tun wenn die fahne schon heiß
geliebt ist und wenn es auch nicht zu
heißt das wenn man einfach wieder
einfach wieder passiert haben wir mal
wieder rein rasiert wird ein bisschen
angeschlagen waren dreckig patrizier 1
er geht jetzt drauf ist alles so ein
bisschen am dünnsten wir geben dem
ganzen noch so 12 minuten würde ich
sagen weil dann ist das ein bisschen
mehr matsche pampe was riecht schon den
c63 t zwischenzeit kurz bisserl die
petersilie ich habe jetzt leider ein
bisschen zu kleinen film von bock
inzwischen sind die hier schon bisher
maximal unterrühren
da kann dann haben wir schon immer mal
die grundsubstanz das hat jetzt ihr
mütchen eingekocht sieht doch schon mal
ganz nice aussage jetzt machen wird
folgendes wir geben hier ein bisschen
petersilie dazu intercity und dann gibt
es noch ein paar gewürze darein wirst
dir gewünscht da wohl schon geschlafen
haben ihr cayenne ich möchte keinen
beweis dass dort noch mehr tote hosen
schaffen noch mal scharf haben aber auch
noch ein bisschen aber auch ein bisschen
rosen aroma aber auch ein bisschen
rosenthal gewartet und da willst du noch
ein klecks einmalig und so ein bisschen
so di di di cultura zu gesprächen
zusammen war alexa in die mitte
dann macht man sie seit den kriegst du
hier die pfeffer symphonie jetzt das
alles mal ein bisschen miteinander zu
einem marnie machen
meine mama ein feiner um haben
mami und jetzt probiere ich mal eine
oberfläche zu machen und dann schlagen
wir hier drauf 4 1 dann deckel drauf die
eier durch brutzeln lassen und dann sind
wir eigentlich auch schon tätig
[Musik]
v leute nicht am extra für die teller
bekommt als erstes probiert man das brot
gut gemacht ich lebe jetzt das
wichtigste problem an als ob eine gabe
zu bekommen nimmt sich das leben zu
nehmen haben dann wird die kamera
ausgehen und dann bewerte ich zwei
gaumenschmaus so viel muss ich sagen wir
kommen ist natürlich zu bewertungen du
bist mein persönlicher koch heute wie
gesagt ultra lecker ultra das passt ja
da drin war
es gibt jedoch ein zwei sachen wo man
kritisieren könnte
ich fand textur vom ein bisschen
software sein caribbean mehr in richtung
pochiertes ei jetzt getan mit dem plan
brot ist denke ich jetzt kürzer und sein
okay aber das muss sagen kann aller
gerichte wenn man das vor sagt finde ich
immer falsch weit eingerichteten musik
lieber draußen ist ist aber irgendwie
eine klassische achteinhalb gewesen
8,5 punkte was ein sehr leiser start ist
also ich habe ja natürlich dadurch dass
ich das kochen und ich gebe mir immer
großen mir ich habe auch einen hohen
anspruch aber das ist ein geiles
frühstück was wir dort nämlich gezaubert
hat protestiert uhr zwar schnell also
schnell so lecker bord nachmachen nach
nach die leute wir sehen uns zum
mittagessen und du kannst gerne sagen
was du machst ich freue mich sehr darauf
weil du bist der könig wieder machen
eine polonaise wir sind ja da zum
mittagessen und ich habe bereits den
größten hunger denn wir haben nicht vor
10 minuten aufgehört die köchelte weil
wir sind damit erst angekommen du hast
bereits alles vorbereitet was hast du
dir fein ist eingetreten
es gibt tolle sachen wir haben einmal
rinder hackfleisch wir haben bacon
wir haben einmal brachen vor können aber
auch inder vornehmen wir haben eine
rotwein
wir haben einen müssten wir okay dann
covert zweifel eine große weg hätte
tomaten einfach geil tomaten bisschen
honig um süßen nochmal drei zu bringen
und tomatenmark ist scharf aber macht
selbst wenn man kann so viel machen und
man kann nun machen kalt ist erstmal
schnippeln auch angesagt tatsächlich
hackfleisch und so kann schon draußen
sein weil wenn das ein bisschen
zimmertemperatur annimmt dann geht mir
ganz selbst raus weniger reiniger
bayerisch trips erstmal zwiebel in
kleine stückchen das ist so trittin er
mit seinem kühlschrank wird das hier ist
die ganze welt erkunden
erfüllt ein bisschen so der montana
black effekt not make an würfeln oder in
kleine stückchen eben wie gesagt nur die
einbürgerung die kleinen stücken gemacht
wird die gibt auch noch mal ein bisschen
süße rein das heißt ich mache im prinzip
immer die wechselwirkung zwischen zum
einen charme und zum anderen halt süße
aber so natürliche süßungsmittel halt
eben eine möhre wie honig also zucker
oder sowas würde ich es nicht daran dass
viele andere noch machen
ok du kriegst nix ist eine möhre ist
thomas wie du automatisch gegen einen
blick hat einem kleinen ort in kleine
stückchen ich habe messer ist noch mal
scharf gemacht damit macht es hier den
ultimativen messerscharf formate stehen
und dumme kommentare gehen wir auch mal
meinen tag genießen das gibt es für
einen kommentar ab bei größeren
verschärfung von batten company hat den
ich mach das jetzt eine kleine
würfelchen entstehen es ansteigt wenn
man nicht ob ein cabrio eine katze
online zeigt arte zweifel so dass wird
angeboten jetzt kommt unser hat wie das
tschechien
nach dem buffet sich muss zwischen ich
noch mal sagen piep riskiert das ist ja
dass wir diese menge mich und für die
zuschauer sich vor allem deshalb schaut
weiß nicht vorbei hier sind jetzt schon
klar sich dann kommen die mütter rein
lassen sich ganz andere gedanken direkt
eigentlich die für mich bedeutete little
bit of labour genau wie brüstet von
markus so kommt
das wird es nochmal ein bisschen angebot
dann kommt das fleisch direkt wieder
dazu und dann gibt es direkt tomatenmark
schlüssel aber was wir dann nach
vormachen wenn das fleisch wieder da ist
wenn dieses versalzen ein bisschen
sieben bisher so ein raster tue ich und
jetzt kommt im prinzip nur noch wieder
unser hackfleisch dazu jetzt macht ein
bisschen salz mal sogar 14 miteinander
vermischen alternativer titel vom video
einen tag persönlicher kameramann
bestimmen dann und hier schöner batzen
das alles jetzt mal unter vision ein
bisschen an prozent lassen besser der
zuschauer aus dem weltmeisterschafts
stadion und da stößt da jetzt gleich an
und und und michael ballack jetzt schon
mal ein bisschen ein brutzeln lassen
das sieht doch verfüge über die tektur
in stunden vor nur noch ein brachen dazu
wir sehen uns dann einfach direkt schon
wenn es fertig ist
[Musik]
wir sind wieder da ist ein koop und ich
habe schon wieder den schönen teller
bekommen wo das ist ein neuer player
aufgetaucht auf der map ein salat die
klassische begleitung oder feldsalat
begleitung mit pinienkernen natürlich
mit unserer tipps paprika und morgen
noch heute noch eine übrig hatten damit
ihr auftreten ist hey hier und zwiebel
und feldsalat natürlich - und beachtet
mal bitte die liebe zum detail sprechen
als meine persönliche kopie reingesteckt
hat meine nudeln sind süßen getränken
deine nicht wie ist deine immer so aber
du hast trotzdem für mich so anrichtet
dass wir auf jeden fall extrakt aber
wenn du das ganze im vergleich sitzt
auch die konsistenz meiner bono ist zu
unserem dinner was wir hatten
ich habe mich schon ein bisschen daran
gearbeitet was sind also bin ich genau
ist es ist es eher die klassische rollen
und ich bin ja schon gesagt du musst du
kräftig motto lesestoffs gerät nur ein
schöner pini kann so gerüstet
hier wurde oder so toll dass ich sagen
tut weh aber ich habe hier so
vollgefressen finde ich aber richtig und
gut begonnen diese darf man das kann ich
muss wirklich sagen sehr sehr lecker
sehr sehr lecker sehr wichtig dazu und
das wird für mich glaube ich auch ein
fester bestand der porno ring selbst
land der feldsalat musterfragebogen
riese auch sehr reiche konsistenz sehr
saftig die nudeln man das nun wirklich
perfekt gemacht nicht hat ein bisschen
die schärfe note kann ich verstehen ja
die hatten die war so ein bisschen
unstimmig soll mit dem ganzen weil dabei
reiche ich würde sagen insgesamt und
weil ich weiß
bisher ist das für mich okay
das nehme ich an neuen fallen gehören
die wahl von zehn freddy geht dass die
bewertung 10 gar nicht über die lippen
ich halte es mir offen und ich hatte es
mir vor allem hoffen für das abendessen
rechts einfach nur einen bisher ist die
fragen haben nicht mal was für mich
gemacht hast war das größte was ich je
gegessen habe wirklich und ich bin
gespannt ob das tagesform war oder ob es
wieder passieren wird weil das macht er
jetzt für mich als abendessen und soll
durch die komplett herzlich willkommen
zur freddys torten welt ich bin aber ich
bin nicht so gut wie die original muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen aber es wird
jetzt sehr sehr lecker dort ist schonmal
ne das ist es überhaupt das sind levels
das heißt dass das habe ich schon ein
paar mal gemacht da gibt's ein sehr
gutes rezept zu und wir fangen jetzt
erst mal an mit dem teig einen ganzen
block butter 250 gramm der wird jetzt
hier mit mehl 250 gramm mehl und 60
gramm puderzucker auch professional
alles abgegeben ja das geht einfach
schneller ist uns beim backen leider
echt mal lästig ein bisschen sich
vermengen und dann können wir das ja
auch nicht hin schon eltern ja und da
können wir die geburt einfach dazu geben
und dann entsteht ein zeigt und das ist
schon dass das denken
wer weiß ob ich noch so geil finde wenn
ich jetzt einmal gesehen gesehen habe
wie du es zubereitet hast bei es ist
schon die pure ungesund qsl karten
gesunde also trotzdem sagen weg ist noch
schlimmer
so wie sich das gehört weiter dieser
boden jeder mensch einmal ein schöner
ist schöner kleiner aus
aber es war mir schon klar damit damit
also ich mach das jetzt ja auch nur weil
das geht dann auch punkte hier ist ja
ich mir noch ein bisschen aufholen so
weit gut ist halt alles so sehr
professionell
jetzt kommt das schön auf die mittlere
schiene 150 grad umluft und dann nehmen
wir es kurz raus und schütten im prinzip
mit unserem asse darauf die wird sofort
machen werden so machen wir einfach
einmal jedes mal dass mir so ein
bisschen die schale abreiben alle drei
werden jetzt hier brauchen so 120
milliliter um den dreh und dafür
manchmal einfach mal alle 120 ml bin ich
gespannt glaube das könnte 120 ml seien
mehr extra wollte schott und jetzt
machen sie folgendes wir wegkommen kurz
den aufsatz nehmen unsere unsere
zitronenwasser eh nehmen uns einander
schott rum sein dass man muss doch sein
männer dann machen wir nämlich hier
nochmal ein bisschen abgibt von der
zitrone ich mache halt immer übel fehlt
ist in der 3 zitronen wir sind
angesprochen und so ein dann nehmen wir
die esseler mädchen an 241 kommt auch
fern 41 wie viel zucker ist dass das
sind 300 gramm zucker max weil wir
wollen uns ja richtig schön ein rein
gehe und wenn du sagst komfort tut dann
gebe ich dir komfort her du gibst mir
nie wieder laufen ließen
in eine harmonisch wirkende vermasseln
zu sagen warten bis es fertig ist und
dann wurde ich das kurz raus und das
ganz kurz stehen dann machen wir das ein
rein und dann gibt es noch mal den roten
15 minuten direkt dahin springen
weiterhin nur wer einfach nur noch
vielleicht diese masse da reinstellen
letzte
[Musik]
ist das wieder in kauf
damit ist das land bars und ich muss
euch sagen es ist für mich das perfekte
begleitung zu einem nächsten café aber
auch so einfach der absolut zutrauen
ultra cremig für mich als zuzuschauen
wie du das zubereiten hast das ganze
irgendwie so folgt definiert weil diese
undefinierbare trainer um auch die so
krank geschmeckt hat ich hoffe dir
gesagt dass wir das gleiche sein wird
die war für mich immer wie studiert
jetzt weiterhin sind eine zitrone
anlassen anlass uns probieren
ich habe diese kamera vor 30 sekunden
gefühl heraus gemacht jetzt ist sie
wieder an wenn meine letzte gabe das
magic für mich wirklich ist ist das
beste bisher
das ist für mich die ich kenne ist bei
mir auch diesmal absolut die nächste
sensoren dass der patient das muss eine
zehn von zehn sein was ist das bitte für
ein finale für diesen tag ist wirklich
großartig sehr sehr wild müsst ihr nach
ihr habt das gesehen hab sehen ich
wollte ich auch nur dieses video mit
gedrehten damit wie dieses geld oder
sind noch mal machen werde ich danke dir
jetzt verstehe ich auch warum die gäste
wenn ihr immer sagen können wir das
jeden tag machen uns mit ihm verbracht
okay wir sehen dass nächsten sonntag
wieder um 14 uhr
checkt unbedingt prädikat unbedingt wir
machen auch viele teams zusammen aber
das macht auch ganz viele andere tolle
video abchecken wirklich free waffe
macht